the pictures that I'm showing you here
some of them were from the Mong betu
tribe in Africa but they used to do
skull elongation they stopped I believe
in the ' 50s skull elongation has been
happening in different cultures at
different times all throughout history
this person here is from France where
the practice of skull binding was
popular in certain subcultures for a
very long time there's a really
interesting book written in 1931 when
the practice had almost completely died
out it's written by Anthropologist Eric
John dingwall he talks about the
conflict between the country people who
were doing the skull elongation and the
French Elite who wanted to have it
banned because they considered it to be
a form of child mutilation to my
knowledge no one alive today has an
artificially elongated skull this
practice is gone everywhere